[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the observers chief leader writer sonia
soder and the telegraph's chief
political correspondent christopher hope
so a very good evening to both of you
and christopher and sonia will be with
us through until midnight um first
though let's go through what's on
tomorrow's front pages and the telegraph
leads with the ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky pleading with the west
to help avert what he says could become
a genocide of his people
the guardian leads with a scramble by
ukrainian refugees to escape the capital
its headline desperate rush for the last
train from kiev
pray for kiev says the daily mail which
pictures the tv tower there which was
destroyed in a missile attack killing
five people
the sun has just one word for the
russian attack on a holocaust memorial
site in kiev barbaric
reporting on a walkout by more than a
hundred u.n diplomats at the un human
rights council during a speech by the
russian foreign minister the metro has
the headline shunned by the world
the eye leads with what it calls the
siege of kiev and quotes ukraine's
ambassador to the uk who says president
putin is now pursuing a siege starve and
surrender strategy
and the financial times has word of
china offering itself as a peacemaker in
the conflict
and just a reminder that by scanning the
qr code that you can see on screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers for
yourself while you watch us
but let's bring in then sonia soda and
christopher hope to go through some of
these front pages and i noticed on you
that all the front page is once again
dominated by ukraine but each one takes
a different angle because there are so
many different facets to this story
aren't there um you've picked out at the
telegraph's front page first of all and
it pictures uh president um vladimir
zelinski of ukraine and the headline
says that he's pleading with the west to
prevent genocide so
what kind of intervention is he calling
for here
well he did a tweet um today where he
said you know what was the point of sort
of the second world war if if these
things are all going to be allowed to
happen again and he was speaking
specifically about the bombing attack on
a tv tower in kiev which killed uh five
people
uh and damaged a holocaust memorial um
in a very very significant holocaust
memorial for ukraine where you know
which marked
um the deaths of thousands of ukrainian
jews in the second world war and i think
this really that the plea from um
president zielenski really speaks to the
terrible position now that i think
ukraine is in and the west is in which
is that when you get to this stage of
conflict when you've got an aggressor
like russia determined to do so much
damage with no paying no heed to the
loss of civilian life there are only
terrible options and even more terrible
options in a war i think and i
completely understand the appeal for the
west to do more the problem is is when
you take a stand back and look at the
conflict and look at where russia is and
what
what what might happen if the um west
were to intervene militarily directly
which is what either a no-fly zone would
be they've even been some pleas
um for the west to sort of intervene and
bomb the convoys going into kiev which
we think will lead to a siege of the
city
um you know if the west get involved if
nato gets involved that's an escalation
even further escalation and there's no
telling what putin will do next so i
think the west has to do absolutely
everything that it can to minimize the
humanitarian crisis that is now already
on our hands and i think there are some
things that the west really did get
wrong on syria when it came to
humanitarian aid when it came to getting
people out ahead of siege which it
really needs to learn the lesson on this
time but i think
that at the moment
you know escalating the conflict by nato
um countries getting involved directly
could lead to an even worse outcome okay
for the people of ukraine but elsewhere
too christopher do you agree with that
because this article does um it quotes
the chief rabbi of ukraine talking about
that 40 mile long convoy that's outside
at the capitol
saying
bomb it stop it
we've also had these calls as sonja was
saying for a no-fly zone but but again
as she was saying there is this very
difficult decision do you
move in further to protect people does
that draw more people potentially into a
conflict yeah
well at the heart of this is anna it's
self-interest so you have the nato
countries yes of course they're bound by
article five so if one country is
attacked they're all attacked ukraine is
not a nato country and that's what's
holding them back they can't really
afford and then put into their their
risk analysis yet the prospect of taking
on russia jets russia fighters and
certainly by enforcing a no-fly zone
over over ukraine that might lead to
shooting down russian planes russian
jets and that's a problem and and that's
why the west is has to sit there and
watch this 40 mile long
parade of tanks uh descending on kiev
with little to do apart from
warm words and that's the frustration i
think of the ukrainians the ones i speak
to certainly for my podcast they are
really concerned about the fact that all
we're doing is saying well we can't help
here we have to wait and see and that's
not on and that's that's a concern
well yes and sonia obviously the west
would say we have introduced some really
punishing sanctions and if you look at
the front page of the metro um they are
saying that russia is isolated the
picture on the front page is uh pictures
of delegates walking out at the un human
rights um session in geneva when sergey
lavrov was speaking russia's foreign
minister i mean
they they are increasingly isolated
russia i mean how much difference could
that make
well i think that that president putin
will be surprised actually by the
strength of the response from the west
and that that comes through economic
sanctions i think it took longer to
impose um tough sanctions um than than
would have ideally been the case but
they are in place now there's also um
very big actions being taken in terms of
soft power in terms of cultural power so
for example in terms of sporting
contests
um but i think you know
i think there will be a time when we
look back and think how did the west let
it get to this point and um that for me
is is kind of you know maybe it's not a
question for right now because we have
to do what as much as we can
and take the best course of action in in
the moment we find ourselves but i do
think that that historians will look
back on this and there's a very big
question about how the west how nato how
the u.s the uk and europe were so
complacent about putin and about russia
because i think very reasonably the
question that ukrainians might ask us is
how did we let it get to this stage we
were warning you all for years that this
could happen
and and moving on to the financial times
actually in the metro it does say that
of those envoys who didn't walk out
apparently countries like china syria
and venezuela um
that's interesting to bear in mind when
you look at the front page of the
financial times isn't it christopher
because they're saying china is offering
themselves up as a role
in the role as peacemaker how surprising
is that and what exactly are they
offering
well to which many might say about time
because china has sat there um i don't
think it it it it condemned um russia at
the weekend with the vote in the
security council so this is the case
they are signaling that the china is
offering a role as peacemaker that's
that's a really good start and and uh
and and
the quotes in beijing are saying that's
extremely concerned about the harm to
civilians um and now that comments came
after a phone call from the chinese
foreign minister wang yi to his
ukrainian counterpart um i think that
shows a degree of concern because of
course don't forget china is affected by
all of these various sanctions we
brought into place then the the the
removal of our rights to airspace um
over parts of russia um and and uh by
russia towards europe and vice versa
over the eu and britain means that it
will affect trade i think that may be
what's driving china but of course china
will be concerned by the loss of life
particularly with what may be happening
in kiev in the current coming days so i
think that china's put his hand up is a
good sign
would you i mean sonia how much hope do
you think there is for diplomacy now
well i think you've always got to keep
trying it but i think you know
with where president putin's coming from
i think the worrying thing about the
situation is that you know he he's not
he doesn't appear to be acting
rationally he's massively um misjudged
uh there's uh stuff that's leaked media
reports it was sort of pre-written that
suggests that the russians were
expecting this to be a very quick easy
victory and that they would have
basically occupied ukraine by now it
would have surrendered um and they'd be
running things and that you know the end
goal was a sort of united russia belarus
and ukraine
so um he's you know president putin it's
very hard to know um exactly how he's
going to react but you know you've got
to sort of try and keep talking as
expected though
what's been issued from russia and putin
so far is basically nothing short of
ukraine's complete surrender which as a
democratic country country um is
completely intolerable the one thing i
will say about china is china is of
course acting in its own self-interest
as well
and you know i think people will sort of
have a bit of a right rise sort of uh
take at its comment that it's worried
about the welfare of civilians giving
what china is doing to the uiga people
itself there are acts of genocide going
on in china so um it's you know maybe
china can play a role but obviously
china will be acting in its own
self-interest too
and let's move on to the guardian
christopher because they have a
different take a very kind of human
angle to their um front page story
desperate rush for the last train for
from kiev and an and a
touching picture really of a woman on a
train obviously a scramble to get on
that train and a reminder that of of all
the many many many stories not just of
people of being in the direct line of
fire but people making desperate
decisions about their families
that's right and this is where i think
newspapers often come into their own
with this amazing reporting this one by
sean walker in care for the guardian you
know he starts the piercing streams of
children mingled with the barking of
traumatized dogs
and the shouts of soldiers trying to
maintain order um i mean we have seen
the footage on tv of this but they do
think that this is a classic pace of of
really good uh foreign reporting here by
the guardian putting on page one other
papers have done it differently we the
telegraph have done we have done and
we'll see that later but it just shows
the horrors and the choices you've got
to make so quickly you're not sure
what's going to happen next do you hang
around do you stay with your husband or
your partner or do you if you're a woman
leave the the city it seems that women
and children were encouraged to go and
not men either by the police is that
right is that the right call to make or
do you hang around and support and
support your friends and family i mean
and these choices are made in real time
very quickly and i think a lot of people
can look at that and go gosh it could be
any of us yeah so it's hard to put
ourselves in that position isn't it
really tough decisions being made and
let's move inside the metro next sonia
because there was an extraordinary
moment when boris johnson was holding a
news conference in warsaw today when a
ukrainian journalist
stood up and talked about the plight of
the people that she left behind herself
in kiev and talked about the need for a
no-fly zone and
although
we've talked about how that issue of a
no-fly zone has cropped up in copy
elsewhere it's when you have a a story
like this and a woman who speaks so
passionately that the story really cuts
through and makes more headlines doesn't
it
it i think it was such a powerful moment
it was so good to see somebody stand up
and confront the prime minister with the
reality of of what's going on in the
ground uh in ukraine talking about the
experiences of her family and friends
you know i'm sure johnson's aware of it
but there's nothing like hearing it from
somebody who's directly affected and i
just think it speaks to this terrible
terrible dilemma that the west now finds
it in which
really i think it could have avoided by
taking different actions to get up to
this point obviously you know the
benefit of hindsight is a fine thing
but you know the west is in a terrible
position now where if it does if it
doing nothing is not a neutral choice um
there will be mass civilian casualties
you know we're already seeing them but
on a scale that we can't even imagine um
you know cities siege in ukraine which
will cause terrible suffering about the
same thing
really gone christopher very quickly
really got a few well
what was so important she said what's
the alternative prime minister to not
enforcing another fly zone and that's
the problem do you do a safe zone in the
western half of ukraine what do you do
and what is the result there's no
obvious answer and that is the tragedy
okay well christopher hope sonia soda
i'm very pleased to say that you will
stay on there are still loads more
issues that we can discuss at 11 but for
the moment thanks very much indeed